In this unit, I'll teach you about a term called correlation.
It's an important statistical term and in the end of this unit, you'll be able to use it yourself.
Here's the fundamental problem.
Sometimes, there are lines done very nicely like these points over here.
Other times, two variables seem to be utterly unrelated.
Correlation is a measure that lies within -1 all the way to 1.
That tells us how far the data is described by a line.
In both cases, you can fit a line but in one case
it would be a really good description of the data whereas in the others don't.
So the correlation coefficient of what we call r is 1 if the data is perfectly aligned for the line.
It's 0 if there seems to be no relation between the two different axes and the data, and it can also be -1.
In the case where the data in fact is still perfectly aligned but there's a negative relationship
between one variable and the other variable.
Let me see if you got this.
Here are three data sets--in one, we have a strongly positive correlation; in another,
it's above zero, and in the third one, it will be a negative correlation.
Which of these cases best describe those conditions
and use each condition exactly once here.